the political showdown over president
Trump's nominee for the Supreme Court
Brett Kavanaugh begins today and full of
moderate Republicans and red state
Democrats will likely determine
determine if Cavanaugh is confirmed
Maine Republican Susan Collins said
Cavanaugh has quote impressive
credentials and she will quote conduct a
careful thorough vetting Democrats joe
Manchin Heidi Heitkamp and Joe Donnelly
who voted for justice Neal Gorsuch said
they will review Cavanaugh's record
Republican strategist Dan Cena worked
with Cavanaugh in the George W Bush
administration he's also a former senior
advisor to GOP presidential candidate
Mitt Romney and House Speaker Paul Ryan
dan good morning morning what are you
hearing from your Republican colleagues
on Capitol Hill
well they there's a little bit of a
device basically general people are
generally enthusiastic brent is a
standard you know Republican judicial
sort of the profile the standard
standard judicial conservative nominee
Mitt Romney were president of Marco
Rubio be president if Jeb Bush were
president he's likely be the nominee
there is some concern among some in the
Senate Republicans that the White House
at least the president doesn't fully
appreciate how different this is than
the door such situation in other words
when Gorsuch was put through the system
the Republicans have had a 52-48
majority now they effectively have 50 49
because they lost the Alabama Senate
race and John McCain is in be able to
vote so it's a narrow margin secondly
Gorsuch was succeeding scalia so it
didn't change the philosophical
composition of the court this time
Kavanagh would be replacing Kennedy
there's a sense that this is a
generational change in the philosophical
composition of the court so the stakes
are higher and thirdly the Democrats are
much more organized this time than they
were during Gorsuch and the pressure on
the Democrats from their base is far
higher now that if you listen to the
base of Democratic Party they are saying
do everything you can Senator Schumer to
stop this change so what's the practical
result of that realization or new
changing landscape does it mean
essentially the two more quote-unquote
moderate Republican senators Collins and
Burke aus key are gonna just get flooded
is that we're actually yeah absolutely I
mean basically what the Democrats have
to do is flip Murkowski or Collins or
both and that's where all the pressure
is gonna be and you can if you listen to
Cavanaugh last night I mean that was his
his acceptance speech was basically a
letter to Collins and Murkowski
my daughter's looking for him my
daughter's lives
I've tribute to his mother he basically
remind me the binders full of women Mitt
Romney all these women who've worked for
me over 50% I've never heard a judicial
nominee cite the percentage of women
that have been their clerks well why
shouldn't you say that you know I mean I
noticed there was some criticism boy I
shouldn't say that it is true if that
hit that not only is it he's hired a
majority of women law clerks he should
be I I agree - not only is it true but
the reality is is he's not some
firebrand right winger that the
Democrats are gonna try I saw to Senator
Schumer's interview earlier I mean he
you can't put him in that box 11 of his
of his opinions have been adopted by the
US Supreme Court seven of his clerks
have gone on to clerk for Justice
Kennedy I mean he is Kennedy was his
mentor so he's not he's not some
right-wing extremist quickly how does
this play out for Democrats in red
states can they oppose this nomination I
think be enormous pressure on them and I
think that the tension is the following
the Trump is popping more popular in
their states than the Democratic
leadership is and if he decides to
really lean into this it's harder for
these red state Democrats but the
national fundraising arm of the left
you know National Organization for Women
National Action rights abortion National
Abortion Rights actually all these
center-left groups that care about this
issue and things think that roe v-- wade
hangs in the balance here are gonna be
deploying huge amounts of money on these
particular red state Democrats and I
think you know they're gonna have to
basically choose between those two it's
gonna be much tougher than the gorse
it's holding both sides right dancing
they're great to see you think you'd be
able to